[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben willkommen zu einer
neuen folge kikis buck schule hatten wir
lange nicht mehr aber wenn ihr spezielle
wünsche haben so basic rezepte schreibt
jetzt gerne schon direkt in die
kommentare und dann mache ich in meiner
buck schule immer diese klassischen
basic rezepte die man halt braucht wenn
man backen möchte ganz einfach schritt
für schritt erklärt heute gibt's im
lemon curt ich liebe lemon körpers ist
eine eher süße zitronen passte man kann
salz aufstrich verwendet man kann es als
torben füllung nämlich aromatisiert
damit gern meine buttercreme und ist man
darf sich das nicht so sauer vorstellen
so dass begrüßten schütteln muss sondern
das ist eher süß sondern auch zucker mit
dazu und ich mache das immer gerne wenn
ich buttercreme mache habe ich ganz viel
geld übrig und dann mache ich aus meinem
eigelb quasi lemon gehört die ganz
genauen mengenangaben schreibe ich euch
wie immer unten die infobox und ich
starte direkt mit dem rezept ich habe
hier meinen top wir sind einfach eine
pfanne nehmen und da gebe ich jetzt
erstmal die übrig gebliebenen eigelbe so
super resteverwertung übrigens so
einfach alles mit dateien schaden und
dann ist ja das wichtigste ist die
zitrone und da braucht ihr am besten
wenn ich habe es auch nicht schlimm aber
es ist halt schöner wenn ihr da bio
zitrone nimmt weil er dürfte auch die
schale mit verwenden wenn die jetzt
nicht bio wäre dann könnte er die schale
nicht benutzen weil ja gespritzt ist und
dann gibt es noch eine sache zu beachten
nimmt so eine feinere halbe feld ihnen
diese großen viel kann treiben habt habe
ich früher immer gemacht da habe ich
einfach so ein backpapier vorne dran
getan und dann gerieben dann reibt ihr
dadurch feiern probiert das gerne mal zu
hause aus ansonsten verlinke ich euch
meine utensilien sowieso in die infobox
und dann müsst ihr darauf achten dass
über die zitrone bloß nicht die weiße
schale unter der gelben schule mit
reifen in die ist bitter also wirklich
ein oberflächliches gelbe abreiben und
danach fressen wir den saft aus
[Musik]
und weil jetzt die truhen manchmal
richtig groß sind oder richtig klein
schreibt ich euch am besten wie ganz
genau gramm angaben rein weil dann kann
nichts schiefgehen wenn ich jetzt
schreibe drei zitronen dann habt ihr
vielleicht drei kleine und dann schmeckt
das nicht so gut oder er drei richtig
bewusst sondern schmeckt es zu sauer
daher mache ich das so in der infobox
und meine drei neins presse ist jetzt
auch da ich hab's euch durch monate lang
den videos gezeigt und jetzt ist sie
endlich da und die kann halt 3 1 1 weil
hier oben kommen limetten ran und klein
mit zitronen und hier unten kleine
orangen oder pro kleine orangen oder
große zitronen und ein tipp von mir wenn
die zitronen doch sehr groß sind wie bei
mir heute dann schneidet gerne dieses
zipfel oben ab dann könnte besser
drücken und diese reste hier wenn man es
wirklich alles verwertet die schale dem
saft und das jetzt packe ich immer in
die spülmaschine für den nächsten gang
ist gut fürs geschirr und dabei riecht
das dann auch gut in der spülmaschine
oder so als tipp ist ja nicht
wegschmeißen und brauchen wir natürlich
noch zucker gebe ich direkt mit dazu und
ein kleines bisschen speisestärke auch
wenn ein gips verbindet mit ich immer
fan davon für die konsistenz noch so ein
bisschen speisestärke dazu zu geben
alles wird jetzt schön verrührt dass
sich das zu einer homogenen masse
verrückt mit einem schneebesen und dann
gehen wir nicht trotz butter noch mit
dazu und dann kommt das ganze auf dem
herd und wird wirklich bei niedriger
hitze wirklich ganz langsam eingelegt
das kann wirklich fünf bis acht minuten
dauern manchmal auch bis zu zehn minuten
kommt immer auf einem herd an und auf
euren topf oder eine pfanne ihr dann
verwendet
[Musik]
also ich habe die acht minuten auf jeden
fall noch voll gemacht bei mir als erste
stufe acht von neun genommen um das
ganze schön zu erwerben und dann als ich
gemerkt habe es fängt an zu global
runter auf stufe sechs von neun gegangen
und habe dann wirklich die acht minuten
voll gemacht und jetzt ist es so ein
bisschen also es ist schon ein bisschen
eingedeckt aber es wird noch fester so
ein bisschen fester wenn es komplett
abkühlt und das ist das ist jetzt
wirklich super frisch ist müsst ihr das
im kühlschrank aufbewahren und da hält
sechs bis sieben tage ich garantiere
euch morgens aufs brot oder als trottel
füllung oder als kekse los einfach
richtig lecker wenn ich all gibt da hat
dann mache ich es immer selber ansonsten
bin ich ehrlich kaufe ich noch ab und zu
das ist ja auch kein problem und ja ich
wünsche euch jetzt viel spaß zum
nachmachen kurze info noch falls ihr
euch ihn fragt was es mit diesem
stückchen das ist mit den
zitronenschalen stören die nicht nein
die stirn nicht also ihr könnt es drin
lassen ihr müsst es nicht passieren oder
so durch den weg das passt so auf jeden
fall wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen und würde einfach mal seinen
wir sehen uns dann wenn beim nächsten
rezept denn daraus mache ich auch einen
richtig leckere motiv
[Musik]